we begin with the tragic news of
America's deadliest day since the start
of this pandemic yesterday the u.s.
became the first country to record more
than 2,000 deaths in 24 hours
other headlines there are now more than
half a million infections in the US
president Trump says he is eager to
reopen the country but won't lift
restrictions until conditions are safe
and tech giant's Apple and Google are
teaming up to develop tracing software
it will allow public health officials to
get a better sense of people who may
have been infected by coronavirus
carriers we're gonna talk more about
that in a moment
there are signs the infection rate is
slowing down in New York epicenter of
the corona virus for the first time
since the outbreak began there are fewer
people in intensive care units than the
day before Michael George is in New York
City this morning Michael good morning
good morning everyone is looking for
those encouraging signs of hope and one
of them is right behind me the naval
ship Comfort was brought in to take on a
thousand overflow patients but now New
York's governor says most of those beds
may not be needed but officials caution
we still have a long fight ahead this is
the end of the week that famous week
that we spoke about last weekend in
which we what actually was predicted to
happen happens we're starting to see the
leveling off in there coming down
while the rate of new cases slowed the
virus killed more than 11,000 people in
the United States this week nearly half
of them in New York where an old public
cemeteries once a week burials became a
daily operation and no one is saying
it's advisable to end stay at home
orders particularly the doctors on the
White House coronavirus task force this
is not the time to feel that since we
have made such important advance in the
sense of success of the mitigation that
we need to be pulling back at all we
still see cases occurring in the Boston
area and in Chicago but their rate of
increase seems to be stabilizing but
data released this week shows
underserved communities are being
disproportionately hit hard in Illinois
28% of those who tested positive are
African Americans though they make up
15% of the state's population in
Michigan blacks account for 40% of the
positive cases but just 14% of the
population look at all of the structural
issues around all of these health care
inequalities all of these lower-income
jobs it tends to impact individuals and
neighborhoods of color a lot more than
it does another night
overall the number of confirmed cases in
the US has now exceeded half a million
this cannot be a weekend to think we can
let our foot off the gas we're not even
close folks we have to keep with it but
battle lines have been drawn on
gatherings for Sunday's Easter services
in Kansas the governor took the
Republican legislature to court after it
overturned her order limiting religious
services to fewer than 10 people we do
not have time to play political games
during a pandemic of 43 states that have
issued stay-at-home orders at least 18
consider traveling to or from places of
worship to be essential but not father
Carl our cosas at st. Michael's in
Livermore California her first time in
my life as a priest and also as a
Catholic and a Christian I'm not in the
church he'll be online with parishioners
praying right along online is okay at
this moment if we survive for this
catastrophic time if we believing that
it's okay at this moment and health
experts say this weekend is not the time
to abandon social distancing dr. Burke
said this gives us great heart that
we're starting to see that change but
the World Health Organization says
stopping now would only prolong the
crisis Dana all right Michael patience
for everyone thank you